um I should probably get going
everyone of course is a little sad we're
feeling nostalgic with Big Bang Theory
having that in how are we gonna feel in
those the last episode or what can you
tease I'm not gonna tease anything I can
tell you that nobody's going to be
sadder than me it's gonna be really hard
but you know we had a extraordinary run
I didn't want to think about it right
now it's hard to imagine that we're not
going to do it anymore
it's a vibe on set VIN really somber
what's great it's been everybody's
working really hard to make this the
best year ever and I think we're turning
out really good episode so you know the
vibe on the sets really upbeat because
we know it's you know put up or shut up
time now right we're not doing any more
after this year the Big Bang Theory is
coming to an end but it's new beginnings
for Chuck Lorre as his next series the
Kaminski method hits Netflix you having
done Big Bang Theory and mom what made
you want to do the Kaminski method TV
series what made it so special I wanted
to write about getting older because you
know it's happening so that was really
the original impetus for yeah and then
you chose some really iconic actors to
be in this I mean Michael Daleks and
Alan Arkin what was the dynamic like on
set with them there was a lot of fun
working with two men who both the body
of work of each man is unbelievable and
the experience is so much intuition and
just artistry in both men and I got to
see it up close my first thought is what
part of me is not working today and we
are passengers on boat slowly we hope to
see a season 2 with the Kaminski method
is there a guest star that you have on
your wish list I know we had a lot this
season Patti LaBelle just so many but is
there anyone on your list
I haven't put together a wish list yet
but I can tell you I got to work with
Danny DeVito on the first eight and that
was a dream come true because I've
always been a huge fan and that was
extraordinary a scene with Danny and
Michael doesn't get any better than that
[Music]